let's shift to the seahawks for a little
while here we we've talked about the
possibility that russell wilson will be
traded let's say he stays yeah
what is it that the seahawks need to do
above all else by way of personnel
acquisition to make the team better this
offseason
i still think the defense is the number
one thing i look at that needs work hey
look like offensively yeah you know do
they need another running back in the
fold and the offensive line a little bit
better certainly okay but but i still
think when i look at them the biggest
thing
is they're secondary hey i like the two
safeties they got no cover corners in
seattle that that to me is their biggest
issue they have nobody that can you can
go wait it's a big play we need to play
man-to-man
and we need to lock some people down
here on third and four that would be the
number one issue that and listen the
pass rush thing is still real they got a
lot of good defensive lineman
and you know i love jaron reed on the
inside i think he's a baller puna ford
does a really good job for them
but you know guys like lj collier a
first round pick
uh you know carlos dunlap again are good
football players but not like you know
not the guys we've seen up there in
seattle where they can just you can go
are you really going to leave them one
on one all game long i don't know about
that you know that's what made them
great back in the day they had two or
three of those guys at some at certain
points right now i don't know if they
have any of those guys so it to me as
defense is still the biggest issue
personnel wise
and you know another issue they're going
to have is this jamal adams contract
extension how much does he want how much
is it going to take how much do you feel
compelled to justify the investment of
two first-round picks to pay the guy
what he wants this trend that i don't
like of making these big trades whether
it was laramie tunzel jaylen ramsey and
then jamal adams multiple first-round
picks
for a guy who doesn't sign a new
contract on his way through the door it
puts so much leverage on the side of the
player and and if i'm going to flip the
hypothetical around if they would trade
russell wilson all of a sudden you're
going to have jamal adams sounding a lot
like he did when he was with the jets
well
maybe i i think
i feel like jamal adams is pretty you
know bought into what what they're what
they're doing up not if he's not winning
not if he's not winning gotta win you're
right gotta win you're right gotta win
it's gonna be scary there's no doubt but
peter's gonna you know sell to him hey
listen russell i we drafted him when he
was young and he wasn't that great yet
and we were winning i could he's gonna
tell him i can do this again and i gotta
think you know
he he's an amazing football player he's
one of the best in the game on the
defensive side of the ball he covers a
lot of holes for their team
he really does you know i know people
point at mistakes and things like that
but as you heard me say many times this
year i mean they ask him to do things at
safety that no other safety in football
gets asked to do none he can do
everything linebacker pulling guards
fill the hole make a tackle blitz off
the edge you know runs around like his
hair's on fire and tackles everybody
covering receivers 40 yards down the
field you know matching up with the
tight end matching up with he does
everything and for that defense that is
the cam chancellor position and to me
it's it's vital that's why you know like
we've talked about derwin that's why the
chargers drafted derwin james it's that
same position it's a vital to make that
scheme work and i think you know that
they both got each other you know by the
kahunas for lack of a better phrase
there to where they love each other and
they'll get something done 10 o'clock in
london hello
not not a worse phrase although there
are there are worse phrases you could
have used so uh lack of a better uh
definitely not lack of worse uh so i
i i feel like
if they do trade russell wilson
will look back at jamal adams trade and
say they knew what was coming
you know because
the pendulum has to swing back to
defense so you give up a couple of lower
round picks to get jamal adams knowing
that you're going to replenish
potentially yeah eventually when you
trade russell wilson um you can't go all
in on both sides of the world right you
can't you can't no um
i think you're right they're clearly not
all in on their offense no they're
clearly not all in uh so
mike i just i i hear you
added to the fact that we talked about
you know with like the josh allen rumors
and the first pick of the draft and all
those that just tells you it's been on
their radar i mean that's who he is pete
carroll he want i mean he's still that
way that's why russ wants out he's just
going damn okay i give up i give up he
wants to run the ball and play defense
that's what he wants to do i i played
awesome i was the best quarterback in
football for eight eight weeks i had two
games where i made a few mistakes and
they went ah
we're going back to pete's way and i
think he just was like okay that's it so
i they're dying i think they're itching
to go back to that style of football i
really do it's just whether they can you
know figure out how to make these moves
now is really the big question
that part of the story from the athletic
when they had had two bad games russell
wilson had seven total turnovers they
had a short week coming up against the
cardinals they were riding that emotion
from the hail murray play and russell
goes in with ideas on how to fix the
offense and they basically tell him
we'll handle that side of it and he
storms out of the room that's all from
the athletic report that was jarring to
me because the seahawks haven't said
anything publicly there's no way that
came from russell wilson's camp that
came from the seahawks and i'm just kind
of waiting for them
to say something to say anything i don't
you know
last week at the combine if we would
have had a combine but all this stuff
would have been hitting the fan
with john schneider speaking to the
media with pete carroll speaking to the
media and some of these other teams have
done that
i just i i can't help but wonder whether
or not the seahawks are trying to delay
that as long as they possibly can
because they know that every question is
going to be about russ yeah i i i would
expect i would expect them to kind of
just you know be quiet lay in the weeds
for now
they're gonna and then trade them and
then if they do yeah if they do or
certainly they're gonna exhaust all
angles and do their homework and do that
you know i don't think pete carroll and
john schneider are afraid to make
aggressive moves either not that they're
mcveigh or less sneed but they're
certainly not scared to do what they got
to do and kind of push the chips all in
to where they want this team to go and
all that so yeah this is to me the the
the story of the offseason it's russell
wilson and and desean watson and what
the hell happens with these two guys a
quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports